no no doubt this is highly entertaining  in Parts it's riveting it's incredibly  intrusive right I mean you just can't  believe this will be a number one  bestseller good luck to him he'll make  millions but at what cost at what cost  he's blown it with his entire family  absolutely there's no amount of money in  the world that would make me do this to  my family yeah but do you not think  there's an argument that maybe losing  his mother at 12 and let me finish I  know that you're going to get really  upset no there isn't and in fact there's  one thing to do with this book uh rather  than buy it and feather his greedy  little Nest do what I'm gonna do right  now take spare and Chuck it where it  belongs in the bin take it away Tim